[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
métropole de Lyon et de Marseille quels
avenir
7 ans après sa création la métropole de
Lyon a une organisation stabilisée et
détient un important pouvoir d'agir mais
sa gouvernance est critiquée par les
maires des communes situées sur son
territoire qui la juge trop verticale
à contrario la métropole d'Aix-Marseille
Provence s'est avéré largement privé de
moyens d'action et a vu son organisation
évoluer en profondeur sous l'effet de la
loi dite 3DS adoptée en février 2022 loi
que le Sénat avait fortement marqué de
son empreinte en conséquence une mission
transpartisane mise en place par la
commission des lois formule des
recommandations pour chacune de ces
métropoles destinée à améliorer
concrètement leur fonctionnement tout en
dégageant une trajectoire d'évolution
institutionnelle
au terme de ces travaux la mission a
estimé que la métropole de Lyon
collectivité à statut particulier ne
doit pas revenir à un statut
intercommunal mais que sa gouvernance
doit évoluer pour tenir compte des
difficultés exprimées par les maires des
communes la mission a donc travaillé
autour de trois axes d'évolution afin de
renouer avec le destin commun de la
métropole et des communes situées sur
son territoire d'abord prendre
pleinement acte du caractère spécifique
de la métropole de Lyon en modifiant à
la marge son régime électoral ensuite
rééquilibrer les rapports entre la
métropole et les communes pour une
action plus efficace en proximité
enfin garantir une meilleure
contribution de la métropole au
développement équilibré du territoire
régional à 300 km de Lyon la métropole
d'Aix-Marseille Provence est confronté à
des défis très différents liés à la
situation de la ville centre de
Marseille et à la difficulté de la
métropole à exercer effectivement ses
prérogatives la réforme souhaitée par le
législateur dans le cadre de la loi dite
3DS doit permettre de rendre la
métropole d'Aix-Marseille Provence plus
fonctionnelle en simplifiant son
organisation en recensant ses
compétences et en définissant une
méthode de révision de son mode de
financement
cette réforme doit être parachevée
notamment en aplanissant les relations
financières entre la métropole et les
communes membres
parallèlement il convient d'accélérer
les mesures de rééquilibrage pour la
ville de Marseille afin de conforter la
cohérence métropolitaine le plan
Marseillais en grand porté par le
gouvernement doit à cet égard mieux
associer les élus locaux et faire
l'objet d'une évaluation régulière enfin
à terme une évolution institutionnelle
pourra être envisagée afin de la
préparer au mieux la mission juge
nécessaire d'engager une réflexion pour
une organisation institutionnelle de la
métropole choisie par les acteurs locaux
fondés sur un calendrier et une méthode
claire
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]